welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and with us now
being past the halfway point of
snowpiercer things are really starting
to go off the rails throughout this
video we're gonna be breaking down
everything you need to know about the
latest entry including our thoughts
theories and predictions for the future
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you haven't had a chance to check out
episode 6 yet then I highly recommend
that you turn off now please drop a
thumbs up if you've been enjoying the
coverage and don't forget to subscribe
because we're going towards the finale a
full steam ahead
without the way thank you for clicking
this let's get into our breakdown of
snowpiercer episode 6 episode 6 opens
from the perspective of brakeman john
who discusses how he actually enjoys
life on the train
John is of course a member of authority
that enforces law and order on the train
whilst also breaking it on the side he
deals chronal he's actually quite a
contradictory character when you think
about it to me this in general comments
on the train and how hypocritical the
idea of it is it's been set up to
preserve life as abused life as being
the utmost important thing however the
way that the high rock is on the train
treat the life that live on bought it
namely the tale shows that they don't
really value it at all it's an
interesting route to take for the intro
and the character utters the line at
trouble comes sideways which is the
episodes title this may be a reference
to the janitor who said that snowpiercer
was basically just a high-rise building
turned on its side however there are a
lot of interpretations that you can take
throughout this opening the main plot
point of the episode are also set up we
see an electrical failure on board the
train which I think was caused by a leak
that happened in the shootout with the
serial killer we then cut over 2/3 who
are starting to see the train board it
really is they are clearly disappointed
with the murder trial and it looks like
they want justice for Nicky Jay instead
of just ice you know had to do one bad
pun at least in the video now Layton is
also experiencing issues that arise in
coming off
all too quickly and throughout the
episode he suffers badly with withdrawal
symptoms after the titles we joined the
drivers discovering the electrical fault
and Melanie receiving meditation therapy
from Jinju
I think jin-joo being in the quote
unquote engine room with Mel confirms
that she is indeed aware of the
character masquerading as Wilford they
talked about the strike going on in
third and this blowback from the trial
shows how powerful third actually are as
it massively worries Melanie that can
completely overrun the train if they
wanted to and I think the theories at
the tale and third will unite in order
to form the revolution a slowly start to
mount here melanie has pretty much the
way of the world on her shoulders in
this episode as she not only has to
manage the population but also the
technical fault that slowly starts to
develop life is of the utmost importance
to her and she wants to stop a
revolution no matter what revolution is
an important word in snowpiercer
as in not only means to revolt but the
train coming full circle on the planet
is also called a revolution it's a
massive job for one person and I do
think that things are just gonna get too
much for her
clearly trouble is a brewing and we see
best return to a carriage looking how I
look getting a 5 a.m. every Monday
morning to do these videos anyway jion
has realized that after she knocked him
out that he can use it against certain
luxuries from a position in second and
he'd rather have those and then actual
justice he's very much in a good
position as should the revolution begin
he can quickly side with Bess
who is clearly on the side of lighten at
this point however if things go wrong
then he can also resume his place in
authority and I did appreciate this
episode painting him out as a complex
character that shows he's really
duplicitous he's a bad dude but to be
fair pretty much everyone on board the
trainers and all he's doing is abusing
this small power that he has just like
everyone else
elsewhere on the train Leighton is on a
comedown and he blames Zara for
suggesting that he carry out the
investigation which has made him an
outlaw Melanie delivers a speech to
third as they plan to go on strike and
I'm not lying
I've heard a lot better she states that
they should be grateful for what they
have as life in the tail is much worse
and this is often something I think
people feel when they see injustice and
inequality a lot of time the idea of
losing what you have even if it's not
amazing scares you into staying silent
third on the whole seems to symbolize
this and Zara has self but very much
represents a life of apathy where things
are probably almost as bad as they are
on the tail
however the minor luxuries that she has
that made her realize she doesn't want
to go back there this is probably a
reach but numerology the number three
represents the principle of growth and
expansion three possesses free form
energy that doesn't work well with
structure and this isn't some big mental
rant saying new numerology is the thing
I did just google it but this could show
why they chose to be a big focus in the
uprising they may not have done that
intentionally and maybe it happened by
accident because as we know three is a
magic number Gaga chion-in Josie goes to
get Layton and she's able to do this
because of the access chip that he gave
her earlier in the series Layton tells
her that Melanie is the one behind the
curtain which is a nod to the Wizard of
Oz in that it was revealed that the
wizard was just a man using trickery and
dramatic effect to appear in a certain
way this is of course apparent and
Melanie who's used vocal recordings of
Wilfred to make it seem like he's still
in charge Wilfred is almost seen like a
deity a scimitar the wizard in the movie
is and I really did appreciate this tiny
little line Josie takes lighting to a
clinic where a doctor is clearly aware
of what's going on in the drawers now
they're mainly used for some ulterior
motives however she's turned a blind eye
to this because she's had it good which
again it ties into the theme of this
episode John the brakeman knows things
are bad but he's happy with how he has
it the doctor does this too and third
only seem to be questioning things after
their members have been murdered the
doctor learned she's on a secret
blacklist that's been created by Melanie
and this changes her perspective as she
realizes much like third he can't sit in
silence when bad things happen to people
as it may eventually happen to you this
is reflected in Zara who initially
doesn't want to fight but after visiting
Audrey she has a change of heart we also
learned that she's pregnant and it would
be crazy right I just have a theory but
imagine if both
and Josie get pregnant because daddy
Andre you know he likes to play play the
field a bit play the Train some would
say actually naughty boy
now the doctor divulges that there are
11 cause of draws in which melanie has
been carrying out these experiments and
falsely imprisoning people on the list
I'm sort of jumping ahead a bit here but
it initially seems like melanie has been
silencing anyone who stands up against
her
however we later learn that she selected
these people for a number of reasons
they've been chosen for their diversity
knowledge set of skills and more in
order to carry on the human race once
things begin to end or those on the
train aren't gonna live forever and
therefore they need people to carry on
the species which this represents I
actually think this adds a lot of weight
to the theory that Wilfred is in a draw
as he would likely want to see the new
world and who knows he may have even
volunteered to do it and then let
Melanie take his place with the
leadership of the vessel the rest of the
population will likely put their against
their will oh so I can't imagine that
they'll be angered I don't know what way
they're gonna go with this but I would
guess that with the revolution on the
horizon the tale will free these
prisoners and thus they'll have an army
to completely desecrate the Train with
in the tale the woman whose arm was
frozen succumbs to her wounds and it's
quite a sad scene we then watching the
undercarriage that Melanie visits the
leaks and we learned that it's shorting
out the brakes she goes to visit miles
and it becomes clear at the end of the
episode she's keeping him as an ace up
her sleeve she begins to lock down the
Train and angered by this Leighton makes
a mad dash to go and get her
there's also an interesting conversation
with Ruth in which she clearly puts
across her suspicions that something is
up with Wilfred and who knows
she even may be put in a drawer at one
point for asking too many questions
Layton catches up with Melanie and holds
a scalpel to her neck whilst an accident
causes the train to rock from side to
side in what was not gonna lie I thought
it was gonna derail the train for a
second this is when Lincoln grabs her
and she explains the drawers as we
mentioned earlier and Layton discovering
and he's on the list decides to let her
live this shows that perhaps because he
realizes he's one of the special people
he's going to have the promise of a good
life and
he allows more in Justices to continue
happening however I do think that he
also realizes that without Melanie the
Train is in danger and the letter off
scott-free for now so that she can go
and fix it now when going to fix the
Train Melanie says a very interesting
line which is I designed her I can fix
her due to her MIT and Yale engineering
clothing from earlier in the season I
think we can now confirm that she is an
engineer that designed the train and
then Wilfred built it this would
obviously make him have a great deal of
trust in her and this could be why he
may have chosen her to take his position
as the leader
Melanie manages to save snowpiercer but
yeah tense moments I love how LJ is the
only one sitting in first at a table and
she pushes the dessert off showing that
she's more interested in chaos and
breaking things and she is herself all
life Ruth delivers a speech and the tale
also look at a projection of the outside
which they seem to actually really like
perhaps they have it so bad that they
actually just want to see things come
crashing down to take their chances yeah
there's there's a lot of different
interpretations that you can take with
this Leighton goes to Josie and tells
her that he didn't kill Melanie because
he was thinking of the bigger picture
but how long this will last for remains
to be seen obviously he didn't want to
die but yeah I really really enjoyed
this action scene as you know this show
it's often more about drama than
heart-pounding moments but I do feel
like it delivered here it was a nice
change of pace and it's sort of winds
Melanie back around in my eyes after the
last couple of episodes painted her I
was the big bad of the show best returns
to Jinju and the Train celebrates
seemingly forgetting that they almost
had an uprising again they've learned to
be fine with what they have even if
things are bad on the whole and Bennett
gives a rousing speech that toasts
Wilfred and the people chant his name
audrey reminds say that the distraction
will brush things under the carpet for a
while but how long we don't know the
doctor allows Josie and Layton to use a
cabin for love and in the hospitality
office
Melanie brings miles in and appoints him
as an engineer he knows that Layton is
still likely coming for her and this has
him in her back
if she ever needs to use him when she
got the tool out actually thought for a
second that it was the castration one
the LJ used in her bodyguard and for a
second just a second I thought who this
has gotten a bit doc now I actually
think that miles will be a key character
that brings it all crashing down and
though he's gonna be spending a lot of
time with Melanie he's probably still
loyal to Josie Layton who no doubt want
him to cause an uprising if he's gonna
be an engineer then he'll no doubt go to
the engineering room and he might be the
one to let the tail forces travel up the
train he also has train pajamas which is
a nice touch but yeah clearly things are
gonna be getting shaken up within the
next episodes the show's starting to
wind down now and I think very shortly
the truth about Melanie will come out
which will reignite the fire and third
and bring her control and schemes to
light that wraps up the episode and it
was another brilliant one that obviously
loved hear your thoughts on and what
your theories are coming below and let
me know and if you enjoyed this video
and missed any of our other breakdowns
and they're gonna be linked at the end
so please give them a watch you want to
support the challenge from as little as
99 cents a month then please click the
join button below you massively
appreciate you and there's a thank you
your access to content early you want to
come chat to us after the show either
follow us at heavy spoilers or click the
disk or link in the description below
every month we give away free movies to
people our subscribe to the channel this
month he can win the MCU Infinity Saga
box set and all you have to do is
comment on a video and make sure you
subscribe with notifications on more
videos he comment on the more of a
chance of winning so make sure you get
involved the winners gonna be chosen at
random on the 15th of July in the cell
be shipped out from then to ever get to
the prize it's a best of luck that every
only takes part yes